and desean watson had a great great game
this past sunday perfect passer rating
five touchdown passes 400 plus yards
found a receiver to go to on a regular
basis other than deandre hopkins and
it's the showdown it's that that next
potential could it be tom brady and
peyton manning for the next 10 years who
knows maybe it will be deshawn watson
versus patrick mahomes at or don't shake
your head let me finish first let me
just give you my questions because
i'm shaking my head because it's the
mitch trubisky draft
oh i see what you're saying yeah the two
guys that were on the board when the
prayers traded up a spot to get mr bisky
yes when they could have traded down
seven spots and still got patrick
mahomes i i am now on a new um i'm i i
understand that patrick mahomes and
deshawn watson are better quarterbacks
than mitch trubisky i will i will
concede that to you mike florio let's
just start changing the narrative here
solomon thomas where's he been nowhere
we're gonna change the narrative on
america uh this game though mike this is
one of my favorite nfl games because
it's the you never look as bad as your
worst game and you never look as good as
your best game and the texans looked
unbelievable last week and the chiefs
looked really really bad so i expected
to go back in reverse and have the
chiefs winning this game easily i'll say
it easily against the texans on sunday
yeah i uh i agree with you and i think
the chiefs uh they're not wired to lose
two in a row at home and they they got
embarrassed by the colts on sunday night
and and maybe they were feeling a little
too good about themselves maybe they
just thought it was going to be easy and
once patrick mahomes got banged up a
little bit i think he was different than
that guy who
when he's healthy looks like the best
quarterback we've ever seen but to your
point whether it's the 49ers with
solomon thomas you could argue that
jaguars shouldn't have taken leonard
fournette i even though they thought
their quarterback situation was under
control at the time how about the titans
they took corey davis before mahomes and
desean watson the chargers mike williams
as philip rivers is closing in on 40.
and the bengals with john ross can you
imagine what the bengals would be with
mahomes or watson right now okay i'm not
going to give up on corey davis yet
because that's an action guy western
michigan shout out and i think he is
more about the guy throwing him the ball
than corey davis himself
right but you'd still rather have
mahomes or watson probably right
probably i mean especially my homes
especially my homes mahomes is going to
be the face of the league for the next
15 years he's revolutionizing the
quarterback position he's influencing
kids all over the country they're
playing quarterback in a different way
already and it's gonna we're going to
benefit from it i've said this before
and i don't know if i said it to you but
mahomes is like michael jordan from the
standpoint of he's unlocking new
potential for what you can do with your
body and it's changing the way the game
is played and we're going to see over
the next 20 years quarterbacks coming up
who are throwing the ball like a
shortstop who are throwing on the run
off the back foot off of no feet they're
going to develop the skill to do it
because they're going to realize hey we
can do it we don't have to stand there
like statues and have everything just
perfect mechanically you can still get
the ball through the air without doing
all those things that coaches obsess
over take it easy mike jeez
you just leave him
i mean patrick
he's gonna change the culture of america
oh my god wouldn't it have been perfect
though if he'd if he'd ended up in
chicago just like michael jordan it just
would have been too perfect next game
worked out yeah next game eagles vikings
uh both teams three and two kirk cousins
acknowledging this week that he plays
better when he's salty i don't know how
salty he is after the big game against
the giants got a phone call from the
president so maybe he's not salty maybe
he needs to get more insults maybe we
need to pounce on him more to get him to
play better i don't like it that guys
need that external stuff to play their
best i think you play your best no
matter what's going on around you that
said do you think he plays well enough
to beat the eagles uh yes because this
is a great kirk cousins game right here
where it's not a prime time game you can
look back and say this was one of his
big wins even though it won't be
but i the vikings are very good at home
i think you you know in the mike zimmer
era they have been a very good team at
home i'm a little worried about the
vikings offensive line against the
eagles defensive line um but it is it's
a little underman but they have some
studs there that will get after kirk
cousins i think the vikings continue to
figure it out i think they win this game
just so
they can get to a point where kirk
cousins can let them down in a big prime
time spot coming soon
oh well at detroit next week and then if
they get past that one they've got
washington in prime time and i don't see
if it's washington in prime time if
there's anybody else then i'd be
concerned but they got at kansas city
and at dallas coming up that that's
where we're gonna see the real kirk
cousins yeah so they win this game just
so that they can say hey kirk cousins is
not as bad as people make him out to be
he beat the eagles
right and then eventually he'll he'll be
in a spot where we start to think hey
you know what this guy's pretty good and
then and then away it will go in the
wrong direction all right the seahawks
is when we're getting to kirk cousins
prime time game that's going to be
horrendous
yes at dallas on nbc hopefully it won't
be horrendous hopefully it'll be a close
game that everybody watches uh and the
ratings are uh enormous all right
seahawks at the browns the seahawks are
two and three are the i mean the browns
are two and three excuse me the seahawks
are four and one and you know you know
what my my my go-to on this one is short
week for the browns long week for the
seahawks that makes it even harder
browns had to fly home from from
california after losing they got their
butts kicked they don't have a whole lot
of time to turn it around the seahawks
have been plotting this one for over a
week already this one's going to be a
tough one for cleveland to win big cat
it's gonna be a tough one for them to
win but i'm gonna invoke my one jersey
game if you visualize the seahawks
jerseys on the road they're just not the
same not the same team i think the
browns win this game because they need
it more this is the brown season the
seahawks the nfl time and time again we
we find out that the team that needs the
win more somehow kind of eeks it out and
the browns
desperately need a win so
i think i think i also think you're
gonna have this from the browns all
season long where it's up and down back
and forth they beat the ravens
everyone's back on the browns they get
embarrassed by the 49ers everyone's back
off the browns then they come and they
beat the seahawks at one o'clock on
sunday
see and i think that it's setting up for
for
a disappointment in that well this is
going to flip that narrative that you're
right all the signs indicate that this
is where the browns reassert themselves
but i feel like they're just teetering
on the brink and there's going to be
just enough pressure from the seahawks
it's going to push him over all this
talk about odell beckham getting the
football and what's wrong with baker
mayfield and freddie kitchens is
learning on the job the seahawks are
just going to come in and take care of
business and you did that visualize the
jersey's crap when the seahawks went to
pittsburgh a few weeks ago and the
seahawks won there they didn't cover oh
wait no they did cover because that was
the game that big bang got hurt okay
yeah yeah fair point
all right saints at jaguars teddy
bridgewater three-and-oh as a starter
drew dubrise could be back in a couple
of weeks but it still continues to be
the bridgewater show at jacksonville
where gardner minshew despite the record
two and three he has played well do the
saints continue to win without their
franchise quarterback gardner minshew
obviously has played well i actually
think that the jaguars are at a point
now where
you might want to
trade nick foles and see if he can get
anything for him so that you can have
gardner minshew as your quarterback in
the future the saints defensive line is
serious serious serious serious and that
makes me a little nervous about gardner
minshew here so i'm gonna take the
saints because i think i actually
might my credit to you the theory that
drew brees getting injured was actually
very good for this saints season because
it took the pressure off and it doesn't
feel like the saints from the
minneapolis miracle it doesn't feel like
the saints from the uh rams nfc
championship game last year they can
kind of relax a little bit knowing that
team people don't expect them to to win
the nfc south with drew brees out for
six weeks so i think the saints continue
this role right here and teddy
bridgewater continues his
good play for the saints offense
yeah i agree with you and it'll be a
shame to see jacksonville fall to two
and four because i think they're better
than that but uh this is not an easy
weekend for them and i think the saints
will emerge with the victory in london
panthers buccaneers rematch of a week
two game that went very badly for the
panthers in large part because cam
newton was injured but they weren't
calling plays as if cam newton was
injured and they ignored christian
mccaffrey for large chunks of the game
mccaffrey has emerged as one of the best
running backs in the nfl if not the very
best he's got a back issue but it's more
about rest for mccaffrey this week he'll
be good to go or at least he should be
this is a big game for both of these
teams it feels like an nfc south
championship elimination game whoever
loses this game has no chance at ever
catching the saints this year and i
think that's bad news for the buccaneers
because i think the panthers moving in
the right direction with kyle allen at
quarterback i think they're going to get
that win
interesting i actually am going to go
the opposite here i think the pan i
think the bucks uh their strength is
their rush defense i think they'll be
able to do a good job with christian
mccaffrey on sunday you saw last week
they got gashed by the saints can kyle
allen do something like that where he
can basically exploit the fact that the
bucks have a very bad secondary i don't
know i do not think that that's going to
be the same you know way that teddy
bridgewater did it so i i see it a low
scoring game hint you can maybe put this
in and go to sleep take a nap in the
second quarter hint hint but i like the
uh bucks to win this game
yeah i just think the panthers defense
is underrated because we get so caught
up in in the skill position players the
star players that panthers defense is
good and it keeps getting better and i
feel like jameis winston is due for one
of those what in the hell was that
moment we haven't seen one from him in a
while and that's credit to bruce erins
but i feel like it's coming we did see
last week
the the craziest play i've seen in all
my time watching the nfl when jameis
winston took a delay a game penalty
but they didn't whistle the play dead
and then threw an interception so his
his stupidity on the play of the game
play again uh delay game penalty
negated his stupidity on the
interception i've never seen that happen
they were trying to take the delay game
penalty make the field goal easier right
that was from the week earlier
the sixth sunday of the nfl regular
season is coming just two days away
let's keep getting you ready by focusing
on the late games and let's start with
really one of the best games of the day
big cat the 49ers at the rams a regional
broadcast 405 eastern on fox the big
late afternoon game is cowboys at jets
and that just shows you the power of the
cowboys they're three and two the jets
are winless but that's the big draw at 4
25 pm eastern 49ers rams is gonna be the
game to watch though 49ers 4-0 rams are
desperate and i think good enough to
match desperation with talent to come
out with a a much needed victory they
fall to three and three and the 49ers go
to 5-0 and nfc west races over at least
as it relates to the rams yeah this is
the theme of the day when it comes to a
preview for sunday is the desperate
teams looking for a win needing a win
being able to show up and i think the
rams do here i really do and sean
mcveigh has extra you know time to prep
for the 49ers i saw a staff that he's
10-1 in these types of situations the
one being the super bowl loss to bill
belichick which
if you lose to bill belichick i think
you can still say you're a pretty good
coach so i think the rams are going to
throw it through everything they they
have at the 49ers here and the 49ers
defensive or sorry offensive line now is
missing two of their starters and joe
staley and mike mcglinchey so those guys
will hopefully be back to finish the
season but for right now they have to do
this with i think a guy from the aaf
right
a guy who has eight nfl regular season
snaps never started an nfl game and he's
going to be at right tackle and you know
they're going to be sending aaron donald
out to that side they'll put dante
fowler over there that's the weak link
on the offensive line unless he steps up
and they don't have kyle use chick
either which is going to be huge great
fullback big cat they don't have a
backup fullback on the roster they may
have signed somebody we've never heard
of since the use chick injury i think
they had some tryouts on tuesday but
when that
position is so critical to your offense
to not have a clear number two uh it's
kind of surprising because they're going
to misuse chick you look at the way he
blocks he catches he does everything
that takes an element away from the
offense yeah i'd agree so i think rams
rams all day here this will be the game
the rams feel like they get right and
the 49ers won't have to you know they'll
walk away saying you know what we just
played on monday night now we're gonna
play the rams on sunday we're four and
one we're feeling good both teams
walking away not feeling terrible about
this game
remember a couple of years ago it was a
fairly early season thursday night when
the rams and the 49ers were both in the
they stink category they had a barn
burner so hopefully it'll be a good
entertaining game that uh a lot of the
country doesn't see because it's not the
4 25 pm kickoff the 4 25 pm kickoff is
cowboys at the jets sam darnold is back
for the first time since week one the
cowboys are desperate after losing two
in a row and i think they're good enough
to go on the road and beat a jets team
that just doesn't have enough talented
players around their best guys to hold
off a team like the cowboys which seem
to seem to be covered at every position
even when you factor in the injuries to
the two tackles and and the issues the
last two weeks offensively i think
they're going to be more than good
enough to win this game yeah this is a
get right game for the cowboys if you
look at their first three games of the
season when they look like world beaters
it was against teams like the jets so
the cowboys are going to get right
they're going to be 4-2 they're going to
win this one convincingly and then we
get the whole are the cowboys back are
the cowboys a threat in the nfc are the
cowboys the real deal even though
they've lost to the real two teams they
played in the saints and the packers
and they got the eagles coming to town
next sunday night which will go a long
way toward determining who wins the nfc
east because the giants in washington
have faded from the pack already the
sunday night game another desperation
game for both teams it's really an
elimination game not that i have faith
in either team to get to the playoffs
but whoever loses this one is basically
done steelers at one and four chargers
two and three steelers down to devlin
hodges from samford 475 yards against
florida state all-time fcs passing
yardage leader eclipsing steve mcnair
mcnair was the third overall pick in the
draft though hodges was undrafted but he
looked good last week in placing mason
rudolph it could be entertaining and
maybe the steelers are going to find
something in devlin hodges assuming
mason rudolph doesn't get cleared to
play big cat my guy duck devlin hodges
devlin duck hodges he won a duck calling
competition when he was a youth i like
the steelers here
against the spread i can say that right
and i like the steelers though to shock
the world because their defense has kind
of rounded into form here and the
chargers just feel like they don't have
that juice this year i don't know what
it is it's the injuries it's the every
year kind of getting in these situations
where they are the team that everyone
talks about before the season it feels
useless mike i'm gonna say it it feels
useless by the way
are we gonna get to the titans game
because i you stole my take
you st i'm no i am i'm not still your
tank i'm charging you would take robbery
i came up with that week one i'm
charging you a take robbery you've been
going around telling everyone when the
titans i was saying it last year
i said it last year
take robbery you've been arrested
god you just talk loud and fast and
that's your way to win arguments it's
effective yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports